well senator josh hawley of missouri
says there may be a way to stop
this he joins us tonight senator thanks
so much for coming on
galling doesn't really describe this how
can we fix it
well one of the first things that you
have to do tucker is you've got to make
clear that you can't come to this
country get welfare benefits and all
manner of other
handouts from the federal government but
the bite administration has done the
reverse they have eliminated the rules
that said
that you had to show that you could be
independent financially economically
independent before you could come into
the country
and when you throw open the border i
mean listen policy is destiny when you
tell people
that you can come and get welfare when
you say that there's not going to be a
border wall when you say that
unaccompanied minors
will get released into the interior of
the country guess what you create
a border crisis you create a human
smuggling crisis you create a
humanitarian crisis
and that is exactly what president biden
has done
and done it without the consent of the
governed i mean none of this has been
voted on in the congress this is all
being done through the agencies
effectively by executive order so it's
not democratic even
but then to exempt people who are
breaking our laws
from the onerous corona regulations the
rest of us
have been crushed by what message are
they sending to us
well well what they're sending the
message they're sending is
is just lawlessness and it's one
standard for american citizens and one
different standard for people coming
illegally into the country
it is a major public health disaster and
they've created as you've been reporting
on they've created a humanitarian
disaster at the border but also this
tucker
these cartels let's remember nobody sets
foot across that border on the southern
end of it without
the cartels the cartels control that
border
so what joe biden has effectively done
is empower those cartels to make money
empower them to smuggle children empower
them to run drugs
they are now in full control of border
policy because the u.s
president is letting them be